نسمع الكثير من الأشياء حول
اللقاح
وبعض المخاوف من أن الناس لديهم بعض
الأساطير التي
يتم مشاركتها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي مثل
حقيقة أن
اللقاح الذي تم تصميم منصة اللقاح
في غضون يومين
ليس بهذه السرعة  من
المثير للاهتمام حقًا أنه من الرائع حقًا
مدى سرعة تطوير اللقاح ،
لكن الأمر كان أشبه بأخذ الشفرة
الجينية واستخراج جزء من هذا الرمز
الذي يمكن استخدامه لصنع اللقاح ،
لذا فهو يشبه رمز الكمبيوتر أكثر
من صنع مادة بيولوجية  في المختبر على
سبيل المثال ، ولكن أيضًا التكنولوجيا التي
نتحدث عنها لهذه اللقاحات ،
فقد
بدأ الكثير من تلك الأبحاث
منذ عقود مضت حقًا منذ عقدين من
الزمن فيما يتعلق بالتعرف الفعلي على
كيفية إنشاء هذه
الرسائل الجديدة  لقاحات rna ، لذا فهي سريعة ،
عادةً ما تستغرق هذه الأشياء سنوات وليس
شهورًا ،
لكن الكثير من التطور العلمي
حول هذا كان مستمرًا لبعض
الوقت
وهو شيء آخر  إذا كنت قد أصبت بالرغبة في الحصول
على اللقاح ، فأنت لست بحاجة إلى اللقاح ، فهناك
بعض الأشياء التي يجب وضعها في الاعتبار هناك
أيضًا أحدهما هو أنه
إذا كنت قد أصبت بالعدوى الطبيعية
لفيروس كورونا ،
فمن المحتمل أنك فعلت ذلك  تطوير أجسام مضادة
وهذا يمنحك
الحماية ، المشكلة في الوقت الحالي هي أننا لا نعرف كم
من الوقت يستمر هذا النوع من الحماية
ويمكن أن يستمر لفترة طويلة ولكن قد لا يحدث ذلك
ونرى دليلًا على الإصابة مرة أخرى ،
لذلك هذا أحد الأسباب التي يجب عليك القيام بها على
الأرجح  الحصول على اللقاح على أي حال
السبب الثاني هو أن اللقاح
مصمم نوعًا ما
خصيصًا مع هذين
اللقاحين لتهيئة جهاز المناعة
ومن ثم تعزيزه والفكرة
هي أن نوع المناعة التي
تحصل عليها تدوم لفترة أطول وأقوى
من اللقاح أكثر من العدوى الطبيعية ،
لا نعرف ذلك على وجه اليقين
حتى الآن ،
ولكن قد يكون هذا هو الحال ، وهناك شيء
آخر نسمع عنه كثيرًا مع هذه
اللقاحات الجينية على وجه التحديد
هو أنه يمكن أن يتسبب في
إصابتي بالعدوى
، فهل يمكن للقاح  يؤدي في الواقع إلى
إصابتي بفيروس
كورونا ، شيء واحد حول
هذه اللقاحات
هو أنهم لا
يصابون
بالفيروس في الواقع ، وهذا هو عادة ما تفكر به في
اللقاحات
مثل العودة إلى الجدري التي قد تعطيها
قليلاً  الفيروس الذي
يتفاعل معه الجسم لن يجعل الجسم
مريضًا جدًا ولكن الجسم سيتفاعل معه
ومن ثم سيكون لديهم أجسام مضادة في
هذه الحالة ، فأنت فقط تعطي الشفرة
الجينية لجزء من الفيروس كنتيجة لذلك
أنت لا تعطي أي فيروس في الواقع ،
وبالتأكيد لا يوجد فيروس حي على الإطلاق في
اللقاح ولا يمكنك أن
تصاب بالعدوى ،
سنرى نتائج التجارب هذه ،
وسنرى ما سيحدث مع إدارة
الأغذية والعقاقير الأسبوع المقبل
ولكن  الكثير من هذه الأسئلة هي نفس الأنواع من
الأسئلة التي يتم أخذها في
الاعتبار الآن ،
هذا السطر في الأعلى باتجاه النهاية هناك
خط الاستشفاء الذي يمثل الخط الأزرق وتحته
مباشرةً الوفيات المبلغ عنها ، لذا سيرفع تقرير الوفاة اليومي
إليك  نعرف ذلك نحن  لقد حطمت للتو
رقمًا قياسيًا على الإطلاق وهو أمر مرعب ومثير
للغضب بصراحة سانجاي
هذا اليوم ولكن هناك كل الأسباب
للاعتقاد بأن ما سيحدث
خلال الأسابيع الثلاثة المقبلة ليس
مروعًا فحسب ، لكنني أتحدث تاريخيًا
كارثيًا أتحدث عن مستويات 1918
من الألم لمدة شهر ونصف الشهر التاليين أو
نحو ذلك حتى يتم تشغيل اللقاح ،
لقد تابعت ذلك
وتتبعت بالضبط
ما قلته عن كثب جدًا لمعرفة أين نحن
في هذا البلد مقارنة بما
نعرفه على نطاق واسع  باعتبارها أسوأ
كارثة صحية عامة في
تاريخ العالم
منذ 100 عام أو على الأقل بضع
مئات من السنين الماضية
، ونحن نعلم أننا ثلاثة
أضعاف عدد السكان الذي كنا في ذلك الوقت
ولكن لدينا أيضًا علاجات أفضل في المستشفى
كما
تعلمون  نظام سيارة إسعاف
أه
وعلى الرغم من ذلك فقط إذا نظرت إلى
الأرقام التي نتتبعها بنفس السوء
الذي كان عليه في ذلك الوقت ، فهذا يتحدث عن حقيقة أنه
بغض النظر عن مدى حسن حصولنا
علميًا  من حيث هذه
العلاجات وكل
الأشياء الرائعة التي يمكن للطب القيام بها
على الرغم من كل هذا
السلوك البشري لا يزال يخربنا
وهذا هو ما يؤدي إلى هذا
وجون أنت تعرف إذا ما نظرت
إلى نسبة
الوفيات الآن مقارنة بالحالات  صحيح أنه
أفضل
الآن مما كان عليه في المسيرة عندما
كنا لا نزال نحاول معرفة هذا
الشيء مثل ما هو هذا بالضبط
ولكن حتى على الرغم من ذلك لأن الأرقام
المطلقة
مرتفعة جدًا على أساس يومي ، فإن
عدد الأشخاص الذين أصبحوا حديثًا
المصابة على أساس يومي
مرتفعة للغاية ، فلا يهم
تمامًا كما تقول لأن
عدد الديون سيظل معدل الوفيات
مرتفعًا بشكل غير مقبول وفي
مرحلة ما
سنصل إلى الذروة كنت أبحث في
ihme  عارضات الأزياء مرة أخرى الليلة الماضية مع بعض
المصممين ، تستمر الذروة المتوقعة في التحرك ولكن
في وقت ما في شهر يناير
، تكمن المشكلة حقًا في أننا قد نبقى
هناك ونستقر عند هذا
المستوى المرتفع غير
المقبول لفترة طويلة من الزمن  وأعتقد
أن هذا هو مصدر القلق الحقيقي
الآن ، حيث يمكن للإجراءات التي نتخذها في هذه
المرحلة
أن تؤدي إلى انخفاض هذه الذروة بسرعة أكبر ،
ومن المحتمل ألا تتجنب تلك
الذروة أو تضعف تلك الذروة في هذه المرحلة
لأنها تحرك النمو الأسي بسرعة كبيرة
مرتفع جدًا
وأنت تعلم أيضًا أن أنظمة الإسعاف
تكسر 90 في المائة من المستشفيات الآن
بسعتها في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، أين
تذهب
عندما كانت في الشمال الشرقي في المقام الأول ،
كما تعلم مرة أخرى في الربيع ،
على الأقل قلت جيدًا انظر إلى
بقية البلاد  لا تتأثر بقدر
ما يمكنك إرسال المرضى خارج
المنطقة التي تعرف أنها سيئة
ولكن لدينا كل هذا النوع من
فتحات الهروب إذا كانت البلاد بأكملها مشتعلة ،
فما هي فتحة الهروب ، فقد أصبح من
الصعب بشكل متزايد العثور على واحد
نرى أرقامًا  لا يعتقد أي منا
أنه كان من الممكن
رؤية هذا الوباء في الوقت
الحالي لم يكن بهذا السوء على الإطلاق ، بل إنه
يزداد
سوءًا لأن الولايات المتحدة تسجل أرقامًا قياسية
لحالات فيروس كورونا الجديدة في المستشفى  zations
والوفيات يوم الخميس ،
فقد حوالي 14 ألف شخص
حياتهم بسبب
الفيروس منذ عيد الشكر الآن ،
نموذج مؤثر يتوقع أن يتضاعف
عدد القتلى
إلى ما يقرب من 539
ألف شخص
بحلول أبريل أولاً ، وهو عدد أكبر من الأشخاص الذين
يعيشون في أتلانتا
في سكرامنتو أو في كانساس سيتي ميسوري
يحذر الخبراء من أن هناك المزيد من المتاعب في
المستقبل ، لذلك أعتقد أننا لم
نشهد بعد ذروة عيد الشكر ، ومن
المحتمل أن نشهد
المزيد من الارتفاع مع مرور أسبوعين إلى ثلاثة
أسابيع بعد
عطلة عيد الشكر تلك الذروة
مما يضع مزيدًا من الضغط
على الذين يعانون بالفعل  المستشفيات
وأنظمة 9-1-1
ما ينتظرنا في الأشهر القليلة المقبلة
هو في الواقع
أسوأ سيناريو لدينا من حيث
المستشفيات المكتظة من حيث عدد الوفيات
الذي يحدث
، حذر حاكم أوهايو من أن
مستشفيات الولاية تعاني بالفعل من أزمة في
كاليفورنيا والتي ضربت دولة أخرى
أعلى مستوى في يوم واحد للحالات الجديدة الخميس
مع قيام أكثر من 21 ألف شخص بسحب
مكابح الطوارئ مع تقييد قيود جديدة
بالنسبة لقدرة العناية المركزة بالمستشفى ، فإن
المحصلة النهائية هي إذا لم نتحرك الآن ،
فسيكون نظام المستشفى لدينا مرتبكًا ،
فلن نتحرك الآن ، وسنستمر في رؤية معدل الوفيات
يرتفع إلى
المزيد من الأرواح المفقودة مع المستشفيات في
الولاية الذهبية التي تعالج رقمًا قياسيًا  من
المرضى الذين يعانون من التبويض المشترك في وحدة العناية المركزة ،
ستدخل أوامر الإقامة في المنزل الجديدة حيز
التنفيذ بعد 48 ساعة من انخفاض وحدات العناية المركزة في المنطقة
عن 15 في المائة من السعة ،
من المتوقع أن تصل أربع مناطق من أصل خمس إلى
هذا الحد بسرعة ،
بينما تستعد الدول
لتوزيع الآلاف  من جرعات
لقاح الفيروس التاجي في
أقرب وقت ممكن بعد توقيع إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA)
على ما يقول مسؤولو الإدارة إنه
قد يحدث في غضون
الأسبوعين المقبلين ،
سنحصل على أكثر الأشخاص ضعفاً
، ويتم تطعيم عمالنا الأساسيين
جميعًا في غضون ثلاثة أو أربعة
أشهر ، وهو ما يستغرق منا  لنقول
لمنتصف الربيع أن هذا لا يعني أننا خرجنا
من الغابة ولكن هذا يعني أننا
بدأنا في تجاوز الزاوية
الآن يمكننا الحصول على اللقاح على نطاق أوسع
ولكن الأطباء يقولون إنه
جهود ation لا تزال
ضرورية ، وهي رسالة رددها
شاب يبلغ من العمر 23 عامًا في
أريزونا عانى من سكتة دماغية أثناء نوبة مع
الطمع ، اعتقدت أنه إذا مرضت
إذا كانت نتيجة الاختبار إيجابية ، فسأواجه
القليل من المتاعب لكنني "
سأكون على ما يرام ولم أكن على ما يرام ، لذا
أود أن أقول إن الوقت قد حان لبدء التعامل مع
هذا الأمر بجدية أكبر مما أعتقد أن الكثير
من الناس
لديهم مثل ارتداء قناعك في مسافة اجتماعية